maintenant voir bien marré d'alternants
il est parfait en psy dans le bien des
films de jean jacques beineix mortel
transfert
voici jean hugues anglade
jean hugues anglade bonsoir lumbres est
d'abord à toutes les filles qui me
disent toujours dans cette émission il
est super gonzesses il n'y a jamais de
beau mais quand je signale qu'à lui
samuel le bihan ya jean hugues anglade
baladeur balazs et comment ça va très
bien merci
il ya déjà un malaise à peine il arrive
ya déjà un malaise bien alors jean
hugues anglade
en plus vous vous êtes une qualité c'est
qu'on peut dire que vous vous êtes pas
beaucoup de problèmes pour mettre tout
nu parce que j'ai en trêve on commence
fort
non mais au printemps 80 en clôture du
conservatoire vous êtes nu sur scène
dans tête d'or de claudel déjà wii
commence très fort dès l'école quoi oui
et vous n'avez jamais eu tellement de
problèmes en fait j'ai pas de saper j'ai
pas de problème pour me pour me montrer
nue vas-y là il se dit à tort est-ce
qu'ils vont demander le pas tout de
suite à la fin à la fin de l'émission a
dit moi votre premier film dont 82 ça
s'appelait l'indiscrétion de pierre
larry et vous aimez pas en parler
pourquoi
non c'était pas ce que c'était j'étais
comme un jeune acteur assez j'avais le
trac et et ça n'a pas été fait sa part
été un film kate qui s'est déroulée dans
le plaisir quoi le premier film vous
considérez que c'est quoi c'est l'homme
blessé l'homme blessé cette année
d'après 183 patrice chéreau halloween
carrière étonnante avait fait plein de
films en fait donc l'homme blessé qu'un
film très très sensible très beau en 85
subway de besson en 86 évidemment 37 2
le matin de beineix déjà 89 une
magnifique d'un corps nocturne indien 90
nikita besson 94 kings au donc aussi la
même année la reine margot toujours
chéreau et en 96 vous écrivez vous
réalisez ton cas avec votre compagne de
l'époque pamela sous vous l'avez
rencontrée alors c'est mans vous l'avez
rencontré six ans avant de faire le film
alors que vous des signes et le
personnage c'est incroyable cette
histoire oui j'avais déjà commencé à
écrire les premiers traits du personnage
effectivement par une coïncidence assez
heureux je les rencontre et de deux ans
après le début de mon écriture c'est fou
ça bah oui je sais pas si c'est fou en
tout cas c'est bien vous arrivé un soir
aux bains douches
oui c'est votre personnage est là devant
vous oui ça a dû vous faire un choc
ça m'a fait ça m'a fait bizarre mais
j'étais j'étais conquis oui et après le
film la question qui vient à l'esprit
dans ces cas c est ce qu après le film
une fois le film terminé
est-ce que l'existant encore où est ce
que c'était simplement le personnage du
film et puis voilà le film terminé je
crois qu'elle existait par certains
traits de son caractère toujours mais le
après je me suis marié avec elle et et
voilà j'ai récemment divorcée donc tu
vois même pas parler sa vie privée sa
naturelle par ben wallace et c'est tous
ces finalités la fin d'une belle
aventure oui et de niro l'avait draguer
à calan 94 me souviens ce dernier
j'étais dernier au courant d'ailleurs
c'était à l'époque de la delà de la
reine margot mais je m'en suis pas
vraiment rendu compte et je crois en
plus que les que les journaux à scandale
aujourd'hui assez facile ont un peu
quand même amplifié louis ne s'est rien
passé rassurer non je crois non je ne
crois pas bon ou bien alors maintenant
il ya effectivement ma fille
laurent pour jean-yves je le fais parce
que j'aime bien vas-y mortel transfert
donc de beineix avec hélène de
fougerolles yves rénier formidable dans
le film robert hirsch catherine mouchet
et denis podalydès qui fait l inspecteur
de police au passage j'aimerais vous
remercier vous remercie à ce que toute
l'équipe est très touchée vous défendiez
filles puisque vous avez déjà invité
hélène de fougerolles pour en parler
et aujourd'hui on m'invite et non mais
c'est un film qu'on aime bien très
content que c'est pas facile parce que
c'est vrai qu'aux chaînes via
l'ingestion ce serait bien qu'ils
amènent juniors du 100 ici
c'est génial et c'est autant c'est
d'autant mieux qu'en fait pas un film
c'est pas comme l'audi matin serait elle
se vérifie pas la seconde près un film
ça demande du temps pour s'installer et
que là on est en train d'assister à un
retour de de bain de tendance et un bon
bouche à oreille c'est vrai qu'au départ
après ça a été un peu comme ça me
changerait pas vraiment aidé c'est vrai
que malgré tout le film maintenant est
en train de de bain de marquer des
points et on est très on est très
confiants et jean-jacques va se battre
jusqu'au bout pour que le film existe
peut être un petit soldat belle avec ça
tous les matins il part au combat lien
oui c'est même un grand soldat courageux
howell bélier tous ces jeux